okay if an asteroid we're coming to hit
Earth yeah how would we stop it I mean
this is possible right oh yeah so we
know exactly I know the answer so there
two ways you could stop it one of them
is the macho way blow it up blow it blow
it up blow the sucker out of this guy we
know blow stuff up but we don't know is
no way to where the pieces go because
they blow it up now you can have two
parts that are going to hit or all the
pieces what's gonna so a kinder gentler
way is you go up there and you nudge it
out of harm's way if you get there early
enough you nudge it a little that
accumulates and then it misses earth
entirely so there ways you can do it
gravitationally remember call a
gravitational tether so you have another
object and they attract each other okay
and so as they attract each other this
what with gravity
yeah gravity gravity feather gravity so
they attract each other but then this
this object you put up there has rockets
and it pulls aside and then they still
attract each other and it slowly drags
it out of harm's way there'd be a
gravitation get all those movies yeah
yeah then you don't have yet you'll get
the flood New York and stuff like know
how to do it from an engineering point
but there is no funded project in the
world to actually make that happen so we
are just sitting ducks
oh my god we need you to become
engineers solve this one
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going